Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Oltre 100 anni fa,
una donna visionaria e coraggiosa
pronunciò queste parole:
"Ogni generazione di bambini
offre all'umanità la possibilità
di ricostruire il mondo
dalle proprie rovine."
Probabilmente, molti di voi
non la conoscono:
il suo nome era Eglantyne Jebb.
Era una giovane donna inglese
che nel 1919 scese in piazza a Londra
per raccogliere fondi
per i bambini tedeschi e austriaci,
che erano affamati dall'embargo inglese.
Era la fine della prima guerra mondiale;
e per gli inglesi,
i tedeschi e gli austriaci
erano dei nemici,
e le conseguenze sui loro figli
non erano importanti.
Ma per Eglantyne,
questo era intollerabile.
Lei fu accusata di tradimento,
e fu arrestata.
Ma aveva una convinzione fortissima:
non solo che tutti i bambini sono uguali,
ma che nessun bambino, nessun bambino,
può essere considerato un nemico.
La sua convinzione fu così forte
che lei convinse il giudice a rilasciarla
e a pagare la sua cauzione;
ma soprattutto, ha influenzato per sempre
il futuro dei diritti dei bambini
e dell'adolescenza nel mondo.
Perché?
Perché Eglantyne, all'epoca,
aveva avuto due grandi intuizioni.
La prima è che i bambini
non sono degli oggetti.
Oggi sembra normale,
ma all'epoca i bambini appartenevano
agli Stati, ai Governi, ai genitori.
Invece, per Eglantyne
i bambini sono dei soggetti.
E la sua seconda intuizione è che,
in quanto soggetti, hanno dei diritti.
E non solo i diritti di base -
il cibo, l'acqua, la salute.
Ma per Eglantyne il diritto al gioco,
all'istruzione, alla partecipazione -
per lei, insomma, il diritto
di crescere in maniera consapevole.
Fu così potente, la sua visione,
che lei ha ispirato la "Carta
dell'Adolescenza e dell'Infanzia",
la Carta dei Diritti,
che oggi è ratificata
praticamente in tutto il mondo.
E poi, lei ha fondato "Save the Children",
che è l'organizzazione
più grande non governativa
che proprio si occupa di difendere
i diritti dei bambini nel mondo.
Ecco, anche per me incontrare Eglantyne
è stato rivoluzionario.
Non solo perché io penso
che il suo pensiero oggi sia,
in realtà, estremamente attuale -
non esistono dei bambini
che noi possiamo considerare dei nemici -
ma Eglantyne è andata molto oltre.
Lei non vedeva i bambini
semplicemente come degli esseri indifesi
dei quali prendersi cura.
Per Eglantyne, i bambini erano
il miglior investimento sul futuro.
Pensate che cambio di paradigma:
non prendersi cura come atto caritatevole,
ma prendersi cura come investimento
strategico sul futuro del mondo.
Impressionante,
che cosa pensava lei 100 anni fa.
Certo, se noi guardiamo il mondo oggi,
non possiamo dire che siamo rinati
dalle nostre rovine,
né tantomeno che il mondo investe
in maniera strategica sull'infanzia.
E condivido con voi un paio di numeri
per dirvi in quale mondo
disuguale stiamo crescendo.
Il primo riguarda l'Italia.
Nel nostro Paese noi abbiamo
1.384.000 bambini in povertà assoluta.
È il numero più alto degli ultimi 15 anni:
sono quasi due bambini su dieci,
nel nostro Paese, in povertà assoluta.
E se apriamo lo sguardo al mondo,
le cose purtroppo non vanno molto meglio:
negli ultimi due anni,
noi siamo passati da 135
a 276 milioni di persone
che soffrono la fame ogni giorno.
Sono 90 milioni di persone in più,
di cui la metà bambini.
Noi oggi siamo dentro la più grave
crisi alimentare del XXI secolo.
Se dovete pensare al mondo oggi,
pensate come se ci fosse
una tempesta perfetta
che è fatta da tre C:
le conseguenze del Covid,
i Conflitti e la Crisi climatica.
Queste tre C si sono combinate,
e mettono a rischio il mondo.
Però, secondo me, c'è una quarta C
che per me è molto importante,
ed è la C della cura:
ma cura come investimento.
Lo so che vi può sembrare paradossale,
però se ci pensate bene non è così.
Prendersi cura dell'infanzia
come investimento strategico sul futuro:
noi lo vediamo tutti i giorni,
nei nostri progetti.
Recentemente sono stata in Bolivia,
dove abbiamo un progetto
per le ragazze adolescenti:
sono ex bambine di strada.
E questo progetto si occupa
di formazione professionale.
Però è stata unita a un'altra componente,
che è un training sulle abilità emotive.
Cioè la fiducia in sé stessi,
il saper lavorare con gli altri,
l'apertura al nuovo.
Questa combinazione ha portato, in realtà,
dei risultati incredibili:
non solo perché il tasso
di occupabilità è arrivato al 55%,
ma perché è sceso al 50%
il tasso di violenza
nei confronti di queste ragazze,
rispetto a un gruppo
che non ha partecipato.
Cioè, che cosa vuol dire?
Che queste ragazze hanno preso
coscienza dei loro diritti,
hanno avuto la capacità di aspirare
ad un futuro diverso.
Si sono messe in gioco,
sono diventate donne consapevoli
e hanno avuto un impatto
per loro stesse e nella loro comunità.
Per questo [parlo di] cura
come investimento strategico:
e non solo sui diritti di base,
ma per i bambini
e sul loro pensiero critico,
sviluppare il loro pensiero critico.
Alcuni mesi fa, ho fatto
un incontro bellissimo:
ho incontrato una ragazza nigeriana
che si chiama Fatima.
Lei è arrivata in Italia adolescente,
ha fatto un viaggio che nessuno di noi,
qui dentro, vorrebbe mai fare.
Lei ha attraversato il deserto,
è stata venduta ai trafficanti,
è stata prigioniera in Libia,
è sopravvissuta alla traversata
del Mediterraneo.
Ma quello che mi ha colpito
è quello che mi ha raccontato
dopo che è arrivata in Italia.
Cioè lei mi ha detto
che per la prima volta,
una volta arrivata qua,
si è sentita vista,
si è sentita ascoltata.
Perché?
Perché non è stata inserita
in un programma standard,
ma perché gli operatori hanno chiesto
che cosa le poteva
servire in quel momento.
Lei aveva bisogno di raccontare
la sua storia, ma non ci riusciva.
E allora, hanno fatto una cosa speciale:
le hanno dato carta e penna,
e le hanno detto: "scrivi".
E lei ha detto: nessuno,
nessuno fino ad allora
aveva mai pensato
che io potessi creare qualcosa,
che io fossi in grado di scrivere.
Lei ha scritto un racconto,
e ha vinto un premio letterario.
Ma la cosa bella è che questo racconto
le ha dato fiducia in se stessa.
Le ha fatto capire
che lei poteva fare altre cose.
Le ha dato la capacità
di aspirare ad un futuro diverso.
Oggi lei sta studiando,
vuole diventare un diplomatico
perché non vuole che altre persone
debbano subire il suo stesso viaggio.
Probabilmente ce la farà, però -
Perché secondo me la storia di Fatima
è molto importante?
Perché ci aiuta a condividere
un messaggio potentissimo:
quando un adulto, un educatore,
intuisce il potenziale
di un bambino o di un ragazzo,
e glielo fa vedere,
improvvisamente i limiti
che quel bambino si è autoimposto,
o che sono stati in realtà imposti
dal contesto di riferimento,
si sgretolano,
e si aprono quelle che noi chiamiamo
"le porte dell'impossibile".
Perché educare non vuol dire omologare,
ma vuol dire sviluppare
le unicità e i talenti.
Vuol dire educare
attraverso la creatività, l'ascolto,
il linguaggio chiaro, l'apertura al nuovo.
Perché il ruolo bellissimo
che possono avere gli adulti, coi bambini,
è quello di far loro intuire
il loro potere, e come usarlo,
e quindi non come farli diventare
dei meri esecutori.
E se ci pensate bene,
in un mondo di grandi diseguaglianze
e di fratture sociali,
i bambini sono i più grandi ricucitori,
perché possono proprio
ricucire queste fratture.
Quindi, cura come investimento
strategico di lungo periodo,
in cui si può avere un ruolo incredibile.
Ma questo ruolo a chi spetta?
Secondo me, spetta
a tutti noi e a tutti voi.
Spesso si pensa che,
per cambiare il mondo,
bisogna per forza fare
qualcosa di incredibile,
altrimenti è meglio non fare niente.
Non è così, assolutamente non è così.
Quando avevo 22 anni,
ed ero una giovane fundraiser,
sapevo fare bene una cosa,
che era raccogliere fondi per i progetti.
Però, io pensavo di dover fare
qualcosa di più straordinario.
E quindi sono partita
per l'Africa, per l'Uganda,
perché pensavo che il mio straordinario
fosse quello, fosse lavorare lì.
In realtà, ero troppo
emotivamente coinvolta.
E per fortuna ho incontrato
un'altra donna straordinaria -
una cooperante, molto più grande di me -
che mi ha vista
e ha visto che io stavo
omologando il mio potenziale
a uno straordinario a cui non appartenevo.
E lei mi ha fatto capire
che in realtà io avevo altri talenti,
e che potevo metterli in gioco
in quel circuito virtuoso.
Quindi io sono tornata a casa,
ho investito sul mio talento,
ho trovato il mio senso di scopo
e ho capito
che lo straordinario, in realtà,
è investire sulle nostre
competenze migliori.
E con questo,
tutti noi possiamo portare avanti
la rivoluzione di Eglantyne,
che è la cura come
investimento strategico.
La prima cosa che possiamo
fare, sinceramente,
è smettere di pensare
di cambiare il futuro,
perché invece possiamo pensare
di cambiare il presente.
Se ascoltate i ragazzi,
i ragazzi vi dicono
che è il loro presente,
che impatterà sul loro futuro.
E quindi, basta pensare
di rimediare, tamponare:
in realtà, bisogna prevenire e costruire.
E se immaginiamo di cambiare il presente,
allora possiamo immaginare
di vedere i ragazzi
non come dei contenitori da riempire
di esperienze, di emozioni.
I ragazzi, in realtà, sono dei soggetti.
Con una grandissima capacità, e voglia,
di partecipare al loro presente
e al loro futuro.
Ho conosciuto una bambina, a Napoli,
che mi ha detto una cosa bellissima:
"Io il futuro non lo so,
ma comunque lo so meglio di voi
e mi dovete ascoltare".
(Risate)
E secondo me, lì dentro c'è
tutta la potenza dei bambini.
C'è il loro potere.
E soprattutto c'è lo sguardo degli adulti,
che improvvisamente scelgono
di non lavorare "per" i bambini,
ma con i bambini.
E nuovamente, in questo "con"
si aprono le porte dell'impossibile.
Tutti noi, tutti noi,
siamo degli agenti di cambiamento.
Poi possiamo scegliere di agirlo o meno;
ma dobbiamo essere consapevoli
che le nostre azioni,
qualunque esse siano,
andranno ad influenzare
le generazioni future.
Quindi, la cura dell'infanzia
come investimento
appartiene a tutti noi, è trasversale.
Non lo fa solo chi lavora nel mio mondo -
gli educatori, la politica,
le istituzioni -
non lo fanno nemmeno solo i genitori.
Eglantyne non aveva figli,
io non ho figli.
Ma il mondo si cambia così:
un bambino alla volta, vicino o lontano.
È che ci dobbiamo concentrare
non solo sul mondo
che lasciamo ai giovani,
ma sui giovani ai quali lasciamo il mondo.
Eglantyne diceva una cosa bellissima:
che "è impossibile salvare
tutti i bambini del mondo
solo se ci rifiutiamo di farlo".
Grazie.
(Applausi)